good morning John I know what you're
thinking oh my god my little brother
really needs a haircut well I only have
one thing to say to you mister okay John
I wanted to say that I finished the
books that you got Katherine and I for
Christmas and Neuromancer was fantastic
mouse was also fascinating and very cool
but I gave it back to the used bookstore
so that they could sell it to a new
person I liked it so much that I wanted
to pass it on this I like so much that I
kind of maybe want to read again some
and all that book reading has made me
start thinking about book reading and
how much I like it a lot and I'm afraid
that not enough people do and sometimes
I think that that's not because people
don't want to read it I think it's just
because people don't have reasons to
read and so I've got this idea and I got
this idea by looking at some books that
I've been reading and noticing the
blurbs now to know the chief written
blurbs before blurbs are very
interesting to me the idea is that when
a new book comes out they'll ship it
around to a bunch of people and book
review place to review the book and
individual authors like you will herb
the book I'll come up with some
amazingly short sentence that tries to
capture the essence of the book in like
five words for example the one in the
front of this is a mind bender of a reed
which is really remarkably accurate to
thinking about blurbs got me thinking
about book reports do you remember book
reports looking for surly lame you end
up not writing about the book so much
and writing about the author and trying
to write about what other people saying
about the book and not what you think
about the book nothing frustrates me and
I started thinking why don't we have
everyone instead of writing book reports
come up with a sentence that in like
less than ten words captures the essence
of the book it distracts me as being
infinitely more useful and cool and
difficult and interesting than writing a
book report it's also a really good way
to sort of make yourself understand
what's unique and interesting about
something new that you're reading so
with that in mind here's my idea we you
and I and the nerdfighters whatever
nerdfighters want to participate read a
book we read a book every two weeks two
weeks is plenty of time to read a book
and then everybody writes a blurb and
the blur has to be less than ten words
have to try and capture the essence of
the book and a unique and interesting
way it can be humorous it can be
insightful it can be exciting it can be
whatever you wanted to be as long as
it's ten words or less I guess it's the
fighting blurbing book-club barbing book
club the nerd fighting blurring book
club and welcome to the first edition of
the nerdfighting barber club it's begun
i think that we should read 13 little
blue envelopes by warren johnson i think
it's only suitable that we choose a
nerdfighters book to start off the nerd
fighting bar big book club I encourage
everyone upon finishing the book to
write down your thoughts a little bit
trying straighten everything out so that
you can get a good blurb out of this
thing then once you've got your blurb
you can post it in a blog post and send
it to me and then I'll set up a poll and
we're gonna vote for the best one and
that person is going to get one a free
nerdfighter t-shirt and two if they wish
their own face saying their blurb on the
log Brothers channel but I encourage
everyone to go by 13 little blue
envelopes you can get it wherever books
are sold or you can go to nerdfighters
calm right now and click on the little
link in the sidebar so that's my idea I
hope you like it I do so I'm gonna go
start reading 13 little blue envelopes
and I encourage you to do the same John
I will see you later